I can ask you about ariana grande on
season yeah because she said that
basically you are her I hope we loved it
I was just like gosh I hope she's not
disappointed with the experience kind
you know but she just was absolutely
amazing and totally into it
and you know I I love staying connected
I'm going to give you five seconds tell
me where it is
yes did you grow it did you glue it on
what's stuck on there with some epoxy
and and many whales died to make that or
no it's not whales its horses isn't it
it is the manifestation of evil a that
begins on your face eventually once it's
curled up and waxed on the ends it says
I just tied a girl to a railroad track
yeah exactly
you know it's the epitome the epitome of
evil well we were just talking about the
fact that you had us all cracking up I
was that girl theatre where people were
turn around like really really I'm not
happy until they wet themselves it's
really it's really the aim
[Music]
but of all of that my favorite thing was
the day the dance well you know
sometimes you got to open the door the
corral and let the Mustang run their
moves they're not on the radar those
moves you know I dropped it no you
brought it know what I'm saying yeah I
took it from the center of the earth and
put it up on the top of the tree is what
I did yeah basically they they said what
we'd love you to do an evil dance
because there's this amazing space they
created I mean the art direction and
this film is so pretty and beautiful I
loved my lab so yeah and the combo of
also like going so crazy with the
electronics and the New Age or the the
AI and stuff that suddenly there's a
blackout he has to use a lighter
the breakers is it was kind of something
that I thought of at the last minute but
they let me have the dance and they
sinned and I picked the song and it was
yeah it was this old Canadian band that
I grew up with you know evil grows was
the song and yeah it was just off the
hook and fun right in the moment
whatever what do you want to do now okay
once you put the camera over here and
I'll do this old trick I learned from
Dick Van Dyke where I'd where my head
disappears so in real life what what hit
you is that how you grew you know I
never know what's gonna happen my body I
really don't is totally it is completely
out it's it's not it's not organized it
can't it can't really be categorized it
is just yeah I love movement I love you
know I'm not like a dancer but
everything in my life is a dance and
everything is a game greater you know
what I mean when I get up in the morning
I get little roller blades on and I fly
through Beverly Hills like I own the
place and then you know I I just like I
love living a constant state of
discovery and movement
and you know I've started cooking you
know which I'm loving because that's a
dance that's a dance right it's like
just in the middle of it you go wait the
broccoli and you spin and you know stuff
like that
the difference is when I have guests
over and stuff like that and I'm gonna
cook a little something I'll be I'll get
some really good music on and I'll dance
and go from pivot to pivot to pivot and
and every once in a while an egg will
get fired against the window just to set
me free what's your go-to meal now well
I'll just tell you I've been going I've
been learning as I go so you know it's
fantastic Google is amazing you know so
I google something but I never take the
recipe that's presented to me I take I
take the basics you know how to cook a
sword the swordfish steak you know I
seared it you know brown it on one side
and the pan I seasoned it nicely and
then I and then I spend 10 minutes in
the oven you know with the flipped over
in the oven and oh my god and then I put
the broccoli and the mushrooms and the
whole deal and the crazy part is that
even though I'm alone most the time I
have to make it presentable but you do
it's crazy because I'll send it back oh
yeah I'll send it back and then and then
I'll walk out to the kitchen and spit in
it and return it reheat it spit in it
return it you should cook together
something you know what's amazing it's
good
my assistant Nichole just got me black
salt for my birthday
beautiful and a decorative and
everything is saying fantastic really
good okay what's your song you never go
back
[Laughter]
Jamie would James was in here he was
talking about the fact that you are like
one of his idols and an icon of anything
he said doing your characters actually
is what got him friends in school oh my
god so when you look back at your iconic
characters because everything you do
never gotten me friends you know it's
many many friends many of her this one's
gonna be iconic too so when you look
like do you have a favorite can you
don't have favorites they're babies you
know it's a busload of babies I got and
they're all special to me you know in
some way and I really just honestly look
forward to creating new things all the
time you know this is exciting because I
don't know it's obviously up to people
if they like it or not enough but this
character has room to grow whatever this
creature is I'm going to power I mean
this this character hasn't even gotten
to the place where you know people kind
of expect him to go he's he's going but
I have really wonderful ideas I would
love to if it's if there's an
opportunity to well I don't think that
he's realized his apotheosis do you know
what that means I've been testing
everyone today and no one seems to know
what it means
yeah apotheosis is his is the height of
his potential oh yeah we have not seen
the height of the potential of his evil
because I think it's not only gonna be
machines on the outside controlling your
world and making sure his name is
somehow involved and that he's necessary
to your life but he's gonna go inside
your body and the nanotechnology and the
nano machines that are supposed to zap
cells
you know evil cells and stuff but you
know what after a while you won't be
able to live without him you know and I
think he's just that guy he's the guy
that has to control everything cuz he's
absolutely worthless in his own mind
and worthlessness and genius together
are really explosive right I'm Sonic a
little ball of super energy in an
extremely handsome package you know I
think that ultimately Sonic is the
epitome of absolute innocence and
electric play you know and Robotnik has
a sonic shaped hole in his heart so
Sonic has the bucket list right yeah
things he wants to cross off right what
is on Jim Carrey's bucket list something
you still gotta do I wish to burst into
a ball of light come on that's what I
want I kind of do I do it all the time
in my mind yeah it's a weird thing
because you know but it's like there's
there's been rumors out there that I'm
woke but you know what I think of
awakenings you know I don't know what
connotation that word is now taking on
but you know I have had many awakenings
in my life and and the wonderful thing
is that I I tend to hit the snooze
button and go back to sleep for a while
you know and then I can dream the dream
again you know so that's what's
happening for me exactly it you just
keep waking up and keep going to sleep
and keep waking up and keep going to
sleep and that's the way it works well I
have to say Jane because you know you
know and my grandson you know so
basically you know they they grew up she
was addicted to Super Mario I literally
had to take the Machine away and hide it
cuz she was like a crack addict it was
crazy
definitely I come from a generation
where you know it was like oh what a fun
book and you know and snakes and ladders
or some don't wake daddy and all that
kind of stuff which can still be fun by
the way what do I call you grandpa
grandpa really make it painful I know
like we'll be swimming in the ocean or
there's a bunch of people around us and
I'm kind of keeping alone for a file
whatever like that he's gonna grab and
it's a good wave coming grandpa you
think you can handle it grandpa you know
and it's like yeah whatever man I'm
grandpa that's me Grampa what does Jane
introduce you to something she's
introducing you that you like would not
have any idea if she had well she was
this she was the chef first oh hey she
got fascinated with that and it's
hilarious cuz she's she's vegan and
she's been doing that for five years and
she loves it loves it and I cannot stop
offering her meat literally I cannot get
into my crust that she will have meat
you know I'm just like I'm the guy at
the dinner in the restaurant that's like
[Music]
because she said that basically you are
her number one how does that make well I
I feel the same way you know I look to
new generations of artists and I admire
them so much I mean it's another level
of excellence that's happening in music
with people like her and and in in film
I think we're coming into another golden
age I think there's extraordinary films
being made you know there's really and
in turbulent times I think artists
really shine you know and it motivates
artists to do incredible things so I was
a great fun she's so fun and so sweet
she was amazing and totally down to
earth and amazing you know I loved it I
was just like gosh I hope she's not
disappointed with the experience because
it's a grind you know
Jesus was absolutely amazing and totally
into it and you know III I love staying
connected we're all artists you know and
and art is ageless you know so it's a
really wonderful thing to be able to
hang with the gang
[Music]